so I was in a new large garage and
because response I got in there I had to
employ people
well as soon as you employ people like
you may not work for yourself like I did
but as soon as you employ people you
have to start
being concerned with their needs
they would
come up to you and
tell you their problems
they would ask for more money you would
have to think how you could pay them
more money
it's a very stressful thing being a
the owner of a business especially when
you started with no money apart from
what you borrowed from the bank
and you're trying to make money to pay
the bank pay the rent now that is a
hundred times more than
what the rent was
when you were in that small shed
and yet
all these hours that I spent working
wiring trying to bring it bring up my
first daughter
um I had two daughters at the end but
anyway my first daughter
paid for the mortgage traveling 17 miles
one way then back
this went on and I was pleased to say
that after some time I think it was
within the first year I can't really
remember of being in Cambridge I
obtained my orange belt
by then the world was my oyster as far
as
I could I was concerned
I was so in love with the art
that I asked my teacher
if we could have a another night
he had another heart attack
so he was on his fourth heart attack
and he said he was concerned if he'd
done more
it would be rather detrimental to his
health
but he said if you want to
train and you can get somebody else to
train with you I'm sure that the Judo
people will find you a slot
we trained regularly on a Thursday
evening
I found a slot at the same time on a
Tuesday evening
and I said if anybody wants to try and
let's let's uh
train
at first this was a great idea but then
you get people say
and I don't know if it's just in my
instincts of being a boss in my own
business but Pete would start asking me
what techniques should we do
and then they'd say well
how do you do this how do you do that
so slowly I was molded into a
teacher without knowing it at orange
belt
this concerned me a lot because nobody
wants to make mistakes and give out the
wrong information
and we were having quite a small group
of people I can't remember how many
exactly
so I asked my teacher if he could um
get me an introduction to go to London
where I could get taught by the very
best in the UK
we arranged that I could go on a Sunday
morning
I was an orange belt so I couldn't go on
a Monday evening because on a Monday
evening it was for first queues and
above where they would practice weapons
and in those days unless she was a first
queue you weren't allowed to do Ken or
Joe
and now
looking back I can understand why
um
so every Sunday morning I would not go
to my work where I used to work from 10
till three as I said
I would sacrifice that money and opening
to go to London where I'd be taught
I I would do this with a friend and my
friend who was
uh much quicker and better than me at
picking things up
I always remember thinking how can he
get things so quick when it takes me so
long
by the time I didn't think that it was
my dyslexic mind the way it sees things
but I'm just a very very slow learner
but once he's in
it's in
so every Sunday
I can't remember if he would come to me
or I would go to him but we would go to
London Hillingdon
and we would go in the sun the snow the
fog sometimes you couldn't see the cars
in front of you but the passion
of going and training with the best in
the UK and all those High grades
let's say there might be 20 people
perhaps more on the on the tatami and
you could you know hurt an orange belt
you could train with blue belts or the
black belts were frightening because
they'd be so hard they would make you
feel like you're going through a machine
of being minced up and spat out at the
end of it so I would normally just work
with a perhaps green belts and blue
belts third cousin second cues because
to me they felt like iron bars they had
for arms
but
my friend couldn't always make it
but I would have to go
year after year after year I kept going
and going
I was tested by them
up to First queue
and at this point
my teacher had just had his eighth heart
attack
and he said to me when he come out of
Hospital
that he decided that
he wasn't able to teach any longer
and he got to make a decision
but the club was going well it had a
good number of students I can't remember
again how many but it had a good number
of students Aikido in those days
was uh very popular and going well
now my Tom and my friend who was the
same grade as me
he was just the model student I mean
there's nothing he was smooth he was
better than me in every way
and I was quite surprised because I was
just happy to be a student loving my
Akita
so
one day when he was about to hand over
the club
he was presenting
me with my brown belt I can't remember
if my friend had already got his bowel
mouth but he was superb and I I was the
clumsy one of the two
even though I'd attended more
seminars than he did but he could I
could pick it up from a seminar go back
show him and within a few minutes he
would have the technique better than I
had it and him not being the one on the
seminar
I went out the front to collect my brown
belt because it was going to be
presented to me
and he said
I'm not only giving you the brown belt
so I'm choking a little bit here
I'm going to hand you over the club
and you wanted me to
take on the Cambridge Aikido Club
sorry I didn't know this was gonna
affect me like this
I was absolutely astounded I didn't want
to be the teacher and after
because you're not allowed to say on the
mat we had a very strict regime in those
days of martialness
but afterwards
I asked him I personally met him off the
mat when he was at work one day
and I asked him why he didn't give it to
my friend
who should really be the teacher
who you just said I've chosen you
sorry
deep breaths
I went to uh London I kept going to
London for my
first and I passed
I trained and trained at and in 19
I decided that um
I was a second Dan
I made my first hand I received my
second Dan from the heart in Hillingdon
again the same people
but they were not using me so much
that's okay anymore
I was getting quite concerned I thought
I'd upset them
I started going to seminars every month
before that I'd been going to seminars
anyhow
I found that people didn't really like
me you know often show you my hands
they're very big hands but I was just
born a very strong powerful person
wherever I went I could stop people from
doing the techniques on me
I didn't realize but I asked my best
friend in London that would make more
friends by then why don't uh present
these uh use me anymore
the answer was you're making them look
bad they can't move you Tony don't you
realize
well having the mind of a child no I
didn't realize I was being honest if
they say grab me then I grabbed them
I've always been like this person if
somebody asked me to give them my word I
give them my word it's to me it's not a
big deal you know just be be honest
of course over the years I've lied I've
had to run a business I like to lie at
times and for what I felt was my benefit
I had to keep my ego polished
so
I've become secondhand I would stop
being used by my senses I thought this
is time I need to find a sensei
I won't mention the names but because
most of them have passed now
by searched out yeah I searched out the
seminar by this time many Japanese top
senses seventh the hands eighth dance
six dance they were all coming to the UK
because I like it I was had branched out
and there were many many different
schools by the time I got from that
orange about those days to the second
damn black belt days
many many organizations had started
thousands of people were training in
Aikido in the UK and throughout Europe
France was the biggest amount of
practitioners outside of Japan doing
Aikido
so I went there as well
wherever I went I could not find what I
wanted and that is people to either
throw me easily
um if I Attack 100 then I'm giving
myself 100 why couldn't they do their
part of the the deal was saying
but they couldn't
so I was lost and not knowing what to do
because I couldn't find any master
in the UK
Japanese Master as well and as the
Japanese Masters came over I saw about
six of them from around the world some
from America some direct from Japan we
had one in the UK that was a permanent
residence
I I will mention the name here I never
trained with scentsychiba I think if I
had a done apart from him fighting me to
death on these films I think I would
have perhaps followed him because I know
that he would have been able to
carry out his his Viking out on me being
such a powerful master
and now
I will continue this story because it's
long I hope you're prepared in stages
travel this journey with me and I
apologize for the haircut when I got
emotional
but we are human beings even the hardest
of Masters
oh carry on shortly